there is no place to run there's no
place to hide so I think it's like
layers of nightmares in this film
your family must choose to willingly
sacrifice
one of the three of you in order to
prevent the apocalypse this is one of
those stories where immediately
you start to think if this was happening
to me what would I do for every no you
give us hundreds of thousands of people
are going to die
when I read the script I was like what
is going to happen what are they gonna
choose what is happening right now
he just takes you on this journey of
your imagination and who knows where
your imagination is going to take you
it's kind of challenging it's intense
puts you in a lot of interesting worlds
when you leave your house and go to the
movie theaters well you want to have the
deepest most profound experience
[Music]
and a type of Storytelling when you get
this much broader bigger more complex
experience than you could have possibly
imagined
foreign